once a security guard in a department
store in the uk and now re-elected as
the president of the gambia this is a
historic moment for adam abaro and the
country sworn in after winning the first
free and fair elections in more than 25
years the gambia independent electoral
commission
declared that there was a voter turnout
of about 90 percent
it is a war of hope
and reassurance
a rejection of division and oppression
he fought an aggressive campaign winning
53 percent of the vote
the supreme court rejected the
opposition's claim of irregularities in
the polls well guardians have spoken
they have elected aramobaro
they were entitled to query the results
they went to the court couldn't succeed
the best that could happen right now is
to reunite and unite our efforts and
then you know i mean develop this
country
in 2017 barrow won against jammeh he
refused to concede defeat barrow was
sworn in as president in senegal at the
gambian embassy in dakar
shortly after jamie was ousted out of
power and forced into exile to
equatorial guinea after west african
forces intervened during his time in
office barrow set up the truth and
reconciliation commission perpetrators
faced victims of rape torture and
families of victims of extrajudicial
killings the commission recommended the
prosecution of jammeh and those who have
committed crimes
jammeh's most prominent henchman former
general seoul baji seen here by his side
is now in court
victims see this as a step towards
justice
giving the many crimes that these people
have been accused of committing it is
only proper that we see justice to
happen there is no two ways about it
in a region marked by military coups
almost all elected west african heads of
state attended the ceremony in a show of
support of democracy
his inauguration is viewed as a much
needed step forward for the rule of law
freedom of speech
a victory for the people says barrow
nicholas hawk al jazeera